how much time have you put into
artificial intelligence and a lot we do
a lot of work in my lab on AI what about
sex robots like what rules should they
give for sex robot yeah how much could
that damage interpersonal relations yes
that's a great question that's exactly
the right question in my view so our
concern with sex robots from a liberty
point of view should not in the
slightest be whether you enjoy a sex
robot it's your business all right
the entire body what you want I really
don't I see I find I would be
hard-pressed to to object the problem is
would set but let's back up from the
less provocative it let's come back to
sex well let's take a simpler example
first let's took let's talk about your
children talking to Alexa okay so the
person who designs Alexa wants to make
your child's experience easy and
pleasant and as part of the programming
of Alexa because they want to make Alexa
the obedient servant of your child
it doesn't require your child to say
please Alexa would you you know play the
music for me your child can be as rude
as she wants to Alexa and Alexa will do
what she wants what you should be
concerned about however is not your
child's interaction with Alexa what you
should be concerned about is what your
child is learning from interacting with
Alexa that then she takes to the
playground so now she's rude to other
children so Alexa is corroding our
social fabric Alexa in this example is
making children rude to each other so
our concern is not so much do we make
and do we make you know like Asimov's
laws of robotics do we we it's not that
we want to program the robot so that
they're don't harm you we'd it's true
the first law we don't want the robot to
through an act of commission or omission
harm or allow a human to come to be
harmed it's that we're concerned about
how the robot in interacting with you
might cause you to harm others the robot
the robotic intelligence creates these
externalities these cascade effects so
in the Alexa example we might want to
regulate the programming of devices that
speak to children not because we want to
deprive your daughter of the right to
speak how she wants but because we
recognize that that robot is gonna cause
your daughter to be rude to other people
is it really do you really think yes the
Alexa what's the
that that would make usually but surely
I think it will contribute so that's a
it's an example it's not like I'm not
arguing that Alexis should become
ornately you think it's so novel to kids
that they know it's not a person I don't
think it really alright but we're using
these examples to build a thing so let's
talk about the sex robot okay so some
people believe that actually the the the
the emergence of sex robots which will
surely appear in the next ten or twenty
years will will be a fantastic boon they
think that you'll people be able to
experiment you'll be able to experiment
with same-sex relationships for example
group sex
you might learn to be a better lover so
you could practice with the robots and
therefore you'd be more experienced when
you were having sex with a real human so
they say that you can't get venereal
diseases from a sex robots you can't
hurt their feelings
so people think that the argument based
on ethical grounds is that this would be
terrific
that this will be a benefit other people
have the opposite opinion other people
think that actually having sex with
robots first of all is symbolically and
and conceptually vile they think that
you know it did take sex and converts it
into a kind of a machine literally a
machine like you know function and they
furthermore think that it would result
in you in one having a kind of anonymous
or impersonal interactions with humans
subsequently that you'll be entrained
you know to let's say want an obedient
you know partner for example I don't
have a stand on this like I don't know
which way it's going out and in a way I
don't have to get make a stand on it
because what I'm interested in
recognizing is that when we talk about
having allowing people to have sex with
sex robots not allowing there it's gonna
happen the focus of our concern should
be not what is your experience in your
bedroom when you have sex with a sex
robot our concern is a state like my
interest I have no stake or control over
what you're doing over there but my
interest is in in once you have had that
experience how does that change how you
interact with other people right and
there I think just like anything else
like you can you can make all the
garbage you want in your house but if
you start polluting the environment
you're harming me so now
I have a reason for intervening in your
activities on your land you can't
pollute your own land if that pollution
runs off onto my land hmm and so the
similar argument can be made or look at
autonomous vehicles here's an example
right now we have all roads almost all
roads have just human drivers and in 20
or 30 years almost all roads will
probably have only non human drivers
machines will drive and those autonomous
vehicles probably can be yoked together
they can communicate with each other so
that you'll have like like trains of
cars moving in synchrony like each of
them will be communicating with the
other nearby cars and you'll have
laminar flow where all these vehicles
are smoothly moving and joining the
highway and leaving the highway and
communicating on a citywide scale
slowing traffic down miles away because
they anticipate with AI that there'll be
a jam here if they don't do that and and
I think that'll be actually great I'm
actually looking forward to autonomy I
mean I still like to take my car to a
speedway but you know DRI itself would
stick which I like but you know but in
between we're gonna have a world of what
I call hybrid systems of human driven
cars and autonomous vehicles coexisting
in an on a plane or an even plane and we
need to be worried about that because
these autonomous vehicles when we
interact with them are gonna change how
we interact with each other for example
do we program the autonomous vehicle to
drive at a constant steady speed if
you're the designer of the car you might
say gee I don't want this car to crash I
want the car to drive in a very
predictable fashion and that that's
what's best for the occupants of the car
that's what's gonna allow me to sell
more vehicles but it may be the case
that actually when people are in contact
with such a vehicle they get lulled into
a false sense of security
oh that vehicle never does anything new
I don't need to pay so much attention to
the car in front of me I just drive you
know at a steady clip and then they veer
off and they go to a part of the highway
where they're just human drivers and now
having been lulled into a false sense of
security they cause more collisions he's
not paying attention so that autonomous
vehicle has changed how I Drive in a way
that harms other people so maybe the
programming of the
vehicle should be to occasionally do
erratic things to like suddenly slow
down or speed up a little bit
obliging me to stay vigilant and pay
attention as I'm interacting with that
car so that then when I go to another
part of the highway when I interact with
just humans
I have retained that vigilance once
again the lesson here is is that it's
not just about the one-on-one
interaction between the robotic
artificial intelligence and the human
being it's about how the robots affect
us and in my lab we do many experiments
in social systems where we take a group
of people and we drop online we drop a
bot or in the laboratory we have a
physical robot and we watch how the
presence of the robot doesn't just
modify how the human interacts with a
robot but how the humans interact with
each other so if we put a robot right
there looking at us with its third eye
would we you know would it change how
you and I talk to each other make us
different mmm that's the experiments
we're doing well
clearly in the sex robot realm that's
gonna be a problem I mean we see the
difference between humans that have porn
addictions yeah that's a good example
yeah
porn addictions when people do they
develop this very impersonal way of
communicating with people and they they
think about sex and the objectification
of the opposite sex and a very different
reason a very different way if flavors
the way you flavors your expectations
yes yes and it makes it difficult it can
make it difficult for you to have normal
sexual relationships it has come to see
if your expectations are are guided by
porn and that is going to be radically
magnified by some sort of artificial
life form that you create that's
indistinguishable yes if you can have an
indistinguishable sex partner yeah it is
you know some incredibly beautiful woman
that is a robot and then you or man
let's go man women quite happy to change
their spouses for robots
I wonder if women are gonna be as into
it as men because I think women divide
desire more emotional intimacy I think I
mean on on a scale then men do I I think
I think the jury's still out on know
what what the relative balance between
men and women we might be surprised that
that will be replaceable given x's
societal expectations and women
conformed those and yes a lot of men can
be sure so it could go both ways I don't
I'm not prepared to make a prediction
who's gonna be better off in the gender
debate with the emergence of sex robots
well maybe your way you suggest I don't
know well we're also in this realization
genetically where they're doing genetic
experiments on humans and with the
advent of CRISPR yes emerging technology
in the book too
entirely possible that there's not gonna
be any frumpy bodies anymore that that's
hundreds of years away but yes yes I
think so
I wonder I mean I don't know if it is I
think if they start cracking them out in
China and they start giving birth to
eight foot tall supermen yes 12 inch
dicks yes it's gonna have a real issue
yes yes we will yes that's the least of
it yes entirely possible that in the
future they're gonna have that that
we're gonna that's likely humans yes I
think that is likely the debate is how
far in the future so I don't think we're
gonna start by using these technologies
to cure monogenic diseases so you know
like fallacy Mia for example so a
diseases or certain immune deficiencies
a disease where a single gene is
defective and and those will be the
initial targets but once we start with
that eventually I think there will be
people who will want to genetically
engineer other people their offspring
for example and modified them in the
ways that you suggest maybe not 12-inch
dicks but maybe you know ability to run
fast or something sure far smarter I
mean yeah isn't that one of these side
effects they showed with the genetic
manipulation of these Chinese babies to
eliminate HIV there that they made him
smarter no I don't know if they made
them smarter that what's clear from the
most recent findings I've seen from that
case is that unsurprisingly as anyone
could predict the technology is not good
enough to restrict the mutations to one
particular region of the genome so there
were other changes in the genome and
these children that occurred elsewhere
rather than the targeted region which
was to increase their immunity
to HIV right and we don't know what
those are but those who kill those kids
quickly we could make them better in
some ways we have no way of knowing yet
but I think the conclusion was that it
increased their intelligence I don't I
think it's I have not seen those results
and I think it would be premature find
that it would because they re mature to
come to that go there because yeah there
the problem is also sensationalist
clickbait which is that's what you want
to click you know not just that they do
the HIV and they made them smarter it's
gonna get like 40 percent more clerks
yes versus you know yeah 40 percent that
mean that's
there's just the the nature of humans
right yes just be clear I talked about
the CRISPR example in in in blueprint I
actually talked about these how these
technologies again my lens on it is how
these technologies are gonna change how
we interact with each other and it goes
back to the example we were talking
about at the beginning when we invented
cities that was a technology that
changed how we interacted with each
other mhm
so human being said for a very long time
had been inventing when we invented
weapons that was a technology that
changed how we interact with each other
so we have previously done this kind of
thing he's invented a technology that
change how we interact with each other
and I'm very interested in in the and
discuss some of those implications yeah
I'm I'm incredibly interested in this
because I I love to study history and I
love to study like how crazy the world
was four thousand five thousand years
ago a thousand years ago yes what it's
going to be like in the future I think
our understanding of the consequences of
our actions are so different than
anybody has ever had before we have just
such a broader first of all we have
examples from all over the world now
that we can study very closely which I
don't think really was available to that
many people up entirely recently you
mean I'm sorry you're saying the
examples are more numerous or a capacity
to discern them as higher our capacity
to discern them and just our in-depth
understanding of these various cultures
all over the world like this like what
do you've been telling you today about
these the divers and others we just have
so much more data yes and so much more
of an understanding than ever before yes
I love the idea that we are I mean I
believe that this is probably the best
time ever to be alive
I think that it's probably I think
that's true I think there's certainly a
lot of terrible things that are wrong in
the world today also true but I think
that there's less of that and more good
that Taylor for know I think that's
right and but one of the arguments that
I make is this is a kind of Steven
Pinker argument that you're outlining
which is you know with the emergence of
I mean people are living longer than
they ever have on the whole planet
fewer people in starvation we have less
violence I mean every indicator of human
well-being is up yes and it's partly due
or largely due in the recent last
thousand years to the to the emergence
of the Enlightenment and the Phyllis the
philosophy and the science that was
guided that emerged about 300 years ago
and two hundred and some-odd years ago
and and culminating in the present and
continuing so I think I think this is
not just the kind of so-called Whiggish
view of history it's not just a
progressive sort of fantasy I think it's
the case that these philosophical and
scientific moves that our species made
in the last 200 years has improved our
well-being however as we've been
discussing today it's not just
historical forces that are tending
towards making us better off a deeper
and more ancient and more powerful
forces also at work which is natural
selection it's evolutionary and not just
historical forces that are relevant to
our well-being and we don't just need to
look to philosophers to find the path to
a good life natural selection has
equipped us with these capacities for
love and friendship and cooperation and
teaching and all these good things we've
been discussing that also tend to a good
life so so yes I totally agree with you
we're better off today than we've ever
been
on average across the world however it's
not just that that's contributing to our
well being the this natural selection is
literally why we are in this state now
and why we were hoping this trend will
continue yes we will be in this better
place 50 years from now 100 years from
now
well natural selection doesn't work over
those timescales so those are historical
forces but the point is we are set up
for success yes
you know we are equipped with these you
know you're given five fingers which
make it possible thumb which allows you
to manipulate tools so natural
election has given you an opposable
thumb culture lets you use a computer do
you worry about the circumventing of
this natural process by artificial
intelligence that artificial
intelligence is going to introduce some
new incredibly powerful factor into this
whole chain of events that by having sex
robots and sex or robot workers yes
things becoming automated yes this I'm
concerned I mean this is I think I'm I'm
very concerned about how technology is
gonna affect our economy the these again
these concerns were not the first
generation to face these concerns there
was similar concerns with the Industrial
Revolution that workers were being put
out of work when machines were invented
nevertheless work persisted people still
had jobs to do there was a disruption
there's no doubt about it I think Google
and the information revolution and these
types of robotic automation are
disruptive they're going to affect how
we allocate labor and capital and data
in our society there's no doubt about
all of that I thought you were alluding
to just to check if you were to the
debate which I don't know the answer to
on whether AI will you know is are we
gonna face like a Terminator type
existence where you know the machines
rise up and kill us all or not and you
know very smart people are on both sides
of that debate and I read them all and
like I'm like he's right and then they
read the guy that has the opposite pen
I'm like no no he's right and then it
goes back and forth I don't know who's
writing what goes back to nuance right
yes it is nuance but it's hard to know
whether again we're not talking over our
lifetime over hundreds of years yes
you know is there time a thousand years
from now when the human beings will say
what the hell were our ancestors doing
inventing artificial intelligence
they're wiping us out and I don't know
the answer to that question well I think
there's an issue also with the the
concept of artificial like artificial
life artificial intelligence it's I
think it's going to be life it's just
going to be a life that we've created
and I don't think it's artificial I just
think it's a different kind of life I
think that we're thinking of
biologically based life of sex yes you
know reproduction in terms of the way
we've always known it as being the only
way that life
this but if we can create something and
that something decides to do things it's
live on its own yeah it's silicon-based
life-form like why not why why does like
I have to be something that only exists
through the you know motivation of cells
yes that's very charitable of you and
its people make that claim some people
think that you know those machines in
the distant future will look back at us
as like one stage of evolution that
eliminated in them that we're I've
always said that we are some sort of an
electronic caterpillar yes know that
it's gonna give birth to a butter is
making your cocoon we don't even know he
was going that's a great metaphor I have
a hard time accepting that because
you're a person yes it's against my
interests we're so flawed all these
things we've outlined those are go away
with artificial intelligence is a deep
philosophical question Joe I mean I
don't think it's inevitable and I think
if the single-celled organisms are
sitting around wondering what the future
would going to be like where are we
gonna be replaced will they make
antibiotics and kill us yes what's guess
they are gonna mean this is I mean we
are so flood when the great the ocean we
do pull the fish out of it do you fuck
up the air commit genocide there's all
these things that are real but the
artificial life won't have those
problems because it won't be emotionally
based it won't be biologically based
it'll just exist that's a really good
story we're so flawed why not we're very
we are flawed but we are flawed I think
it's beautiful too but I think vultures
probably think they're beautiful too
that's why they breed with each other
well they are beautiful but but the
point is I think we have a flaw Judy I
like I'm gonna stick to my principles
that we are despite our flaws worth it
but there is something wonderful about
us and I think that wonderful creative
quality is the reason why we created
artificial life in the first place hmm
it's like this this variation we've had
that impetus you know if you look at a
lot of the the art whether it's the
Egyptian you know the the the pyramids
or other kinds of artistic expression we
seem to have had a desire to transcend
death you know to make things that
that looked like us but weren't alive
right forever rightly so I mean I think
in that regard I think you're quite
right that it's not gonna stop that
Tennessee's not gonna stop now you're
you're very as I said charitable
positive take on the claim and your
analogy to single-celled organisms which
were just you know but a fleeting not a
fleeting they're still there but a phase
in our evolution you know is something
I'm gonna have to be thinking about
because it's disturbing honestly well
it's an objective perspective if I took
myself out of the human race which I
really can't but if I tried to fake it I
would say oh I see what's going on here
yeah these are yes these dummies are
buying iPhones and new MacBooks because
they they know that this is what's going
to help the production of newer more
superior technologies the more we
consume it's also based I think in a lot
of ways our insane desire for
materialism is fueling this yeah and it
could be an inherent property of the
human species that it is designed to
create this artificial life and that
literally is what it's here for
and much like an ant is creating an
anthill and doesn't exactly have some
sort of a future plan
you know it's kids and it's 401k plan
that what we're doing is like this
inherent property of being a human being
our curiosity our wanderlust our desire
culture things yeah all these things are
built-in because if you follow them far
enough down the line in a hundred years
200 years it inevitably leads to
artificial life yes I think I think
that's possible and of course we're not
going to be alive to test that idea
there's a Sun well maybe with CRISPR and
all this crazy shit that's coming down
come on no there's nothing's gonna
happen the pace of innovation people
always have good say if you go back
every decade people saying just around
the corner just around the corner these
things that are take forever they're
very hard biological systems are very
hard to engineer I don't and you know of
course the people who do that kind of
work will often I think a lot of them
engage in snake oil you know they'd want
to fund their was sure but I think it's
entirely possible that there's a 20 year
old listening to this podcast possible
maybe a lot more than that